grazie a tutti è un onore per me essere
qua sento il calore del pubblico ma
sento soprattutto il calore del global
warming
la nasa ha appena diffuso i dati delle
temperature globali di settembre 2016
che tanto per cambiare il risultato il
mese di settembre più caldo di sempre
sono ormai oltre 300 mesi consecutivi
che le temperature globali sono sopra i
valori di riferimento del xix secolo ma
come vedete il riscaldamento globale che
è inequivocabile ormai non discutiamo
più selettiva si scalda sarebbe come se
discutere se la terra è rotonda
non è uniforme alcune zone si scaldano
più di altre
e fra queste è proprio la nostra europa
e il polo nord
sono alcuni dei punti caldi degli o spot
the climate change altre subiscono dei
lievi raffreddamenti che sono fra
l'altro come quel blog freddo li sotto
l'oceano atlantico sotto la groenlandia
i corresponsabili delle stagioni
impazzite non ci sono più le mezze
stagioni
il pianeta la febbre ma non vi mostro
questa di è positiva per dire che il
pianeta da febbre perché ce l'ha ma per
dirvi quando dobbiamo preoccuparci delle
ondate di caldo del caldo estivo e
dobbiamo preoccuparci quando riusciamo a
misurare la temperatura atmosferica a
londra con un normale termometro da
febbre e l'ho fatto diverse volte negli
ultimi anni estate del 2003
mai così caldo negli ultimi 46 mila anni
nell'estate 2003 tra l'altro sia stato
un numero elevatissimo di vittime di
eccesso di mortalità in tuto ropa 70.000
vittime 15 mila in italia 20 mila in
francia
un'estate che ha causato più vittime
addirittura delle alluvioni dei tornado
degli uragani luglio 2015 luglio 2015
osservato un'altra cosa come se la
montagna si fosse spostata in città
sesto la ridente località del nostro
appennino tosco emiliano 1000 metri è
stata calda come normalmente era calda
modena nel passato e modena vi
chiederete modena ha avuto diverse
giornate che è stata calda come più che
luxor in egitto nel futuro se noi li
mettiamo i cambiamenti climatici
chiameremo fresco quello che oggi il
caldo più incallito e tutto questo ormai
sappiamo che avviene a causa
dell'aumento dei gas serra in atmosfera
co2 ma non solo
mi concentro parola sulla co2 perché il
principale un gas minore per quantità ma
importante per qualità quando nacque io
320 parti per milione e già valore da
record
oggi ha superato la soglia psicologica
di 400 parti per milione
meritava titoloni sui giornali perché
non era non era così alta da ben 2
milioni e mezzo di anni allora sulla
terra non c'erano gli homo sapiens ma
degli scimmioni come me
l'auto goldbet e cus bari e bologna era
sommersa dall'acqua dal mare e questo
secolo potrebbe essere testimone di
cambiamenti climatici inauditi e di una
distruzione senza precedente degli
ecosistemi con gravi ripercussioni
conseguenze su tutti noi
è il monito di papa francesco in laudato
sì ma ora vi voglio parlare di quando i
cambiamenti climatici se diventano
inauditi e qual è la distruzione degli
ecosistemi 2 gradi 2 gradi di massimo
riscaldamento rispetto all'era pre
industriale
sono uno scenario che è universalmente
riconosciuto dalla comunità scientifica
che ci consentirebbe di convivere con i
cambiamenti climatici con l'adattamento
soprattutto con la resilienza
vi chiederete perché non zero gradi
perché un grado se lo siano già giocati
perché rispetto all'era preindustriale e
almeno mezzo grado si sarà comunque
anche se riuscissimo abbandonare
immediatamente in questo momento i
combustibili fossili
poi dobbiamo scegliere la strada giusta
e questa è una scelta che dipende da noi
e dalla nostra società perché lo segnava
e obx a un business l'uso ad affari come
al solito dalla banca mondiale è
ritenuto incompatibile con la società
globale interconnessa è un modo un po
per gentile per dire che potremmo
estinguerci 4 gradi di riscaldamento
globale o addirittura se andiamo peggio
anche cinque comporterebbero grandi
estinzioni di massa fra il 40 e 60 per
cento delle specie viventi e sarebbe
curioso se fra queste ci fosse anche la
mo sapiens magari non in questo secolo
ma nei successivi ci sono anche le
pubblicazioni scientifiche su questo se
invece scegliamo la strada virtuosa 2
gradi avremo solo si fa per dire la
perdita del 10 15 per cento delle specie
viventi e poi i ghiacciai che sono una
bellezza della natura sono una vera
banca dell'acqua e della neve per i
ghiacciai non vi do buone notizie questo
ghiacciaio ghiacciaio del grossglockner
una passeggiata nei cambiamenti
climatici che vado spesso fare quando
sono nato e dove c'è quella freccia
rossa
e bene indipendentemente se scegliamo i
2 ei 4 gradi e spacciato cambiava solo
l'anno in cui diventava spacciato lui e
tutti quasi tutti gli acciai alpini
fuorché quelli ad alta quota
dobbiamo fare tante cose per limitare i
cambiamenti climatici ma per il momento
ci sono alcune cose che anche io
personalmente non riesco a rinunciare a
questa andava ciare e anche viaggiare
ebbene in base allo studio ocse risulta
che dagli 80 circa impianti di risalita
stazioni sciistiche attive nelle alpi
italiane
se limitiamo il riscaldamento globale
entro i 2 gradi ne rimarrebbero attive
economicamente e con innevamento
sufficiente anche con temperatura
sufficiente per fare la neve artificiale
a parte il problema dell'acqua una
settantina se andiamo verso la strada
sbagliata dei quattro galline libere
bero attive economicamente e con
quantità di neve sostenibile
soltanto una ventina quindi la scelta
non è soltanto ambientale ma anche
economica
invece se andiamo il polo nord del
ritiro dei ghiacci artici marini e
drammatico siamo ai minimi storici c'è
un deficit di ghiaccio questore
settembre 2016 dati della nova di oltre
4 milioni di chilometri di ghiaccio
questo apre da un lato nuove rotte e
nuovi conflitti per le ricerche delle
risorse ma crea anche dei problemi il
primo pensiamo gli orsi polari gli orsi
bianchi campeggiava naturalmente
all'ingresso di coop 21 di parigi un
orso bianco ma il problema del climate
change e del ritiro dei ghiacciai arte
dei ghiacci artici marini non è l'orso
ma il homo sapiens
paradossalmente il ritiro dei ghiacci
artici marini innescando un fenomeno un
po complesso non ve lo so spiegare oggi
l'amplificazione artica espone
maggiormente l'europa e gli stati uniti
orientali a maggiori ondate di freddo e
di gelo improvvise come il nevone 2012
come la grande nevicata paralizzante del
6 febbraio 2015 che mi ha dato tanto da
fare per i miei clienti professionali
fra cui babbo natale perché questa neve
arriva improvvisa poi altrettanto
improvvisa se ne va
ed ecco che aumenta il rischio delle
alluvioni delle inondazioni
non parlate di bombe d'acqua perché non
fanno parte della buona meteo si
chiamano semplicemente nubifragi anche
le trombe d'aria volte se usato
impropriamente questo nome ma questi
fenomeni estremi sono ormai una nuova
normalità e la loro frequenza in futuro
dipenderà
anche dalla nostra scelta e
dall'adattamento resilienza allora
andiamo al mare vi chiederemo beh se
aspettiamo un po se non siamo virtuosi
faccia le scelte sbagliate siamo anche
un po sfortunati perché questo è uno
scenario un po pessimistico ma non
impossibile il mare non arriverà a
bologna ma forse a budrio qui la
periferia qui attorno alla tangenziale
potrebbe arrivare la strada più virtuosa
del grado e mezzo dei 2 gradi perché ha
un grado e mezzo
lo chiedono fortemente le piccole isole
stato perché per loro la questione dei
cambiamenti climatici non è economica ma
di sopravvivenza limiterebbe i danni
anche se per esempio località come
venezia hanno ben poche speranze di
fronte ai guai che abbiamo combinato
che fare dunque si è già parlato prima
di coop 21 c ho partecipato anch'io
entrando si ha una sensazione
contrastante almeno per quanto mi
riguarda va da una parte le speranze le
belle parole
siamo la prima generazione che subisce
gli effetti dei cambiamenti climatici è
l'ultima che può fare qualche cosa per
fermarli ha detto barack obama
dall'altro alle azioni concrete arriverà
questo risultato
dentro la sensazione era molto diversa
che nel mondo esterno nella società
civile
ma com 21 non ha deluso le aspettative è
uscito un grande trattato internazionale
che ha l'obiettivo di limitare il
riscaldamento globale entro i 2 gradi
rispetto all'era pre industriale facendo
ogni sforzo per contenere il
riscaldamento entro un grado e mezzo è
stato già ratificato da 60 stati fra cui
tutti i grandi inquinatori stati uniti
la cina eccetera l'unione europea stiamo
aspettando l'italia come al solito un po
in ritardo ma ci stiamo arrivando
ci arriveremo ma entrerà in vigore
appunto il 4 e 5 novembre alla
conferenza di marrakech che doveva
cominciare ad attuare questo accordo le
parole di ban ki moon per la prima volta
tutte le nazioni del mondo hanno preso
impegni concreti per aumentare la
resilienza e per combattere i
cambiamenti climatici
quello che sembrava impossibile è
diventato inarrestabile l'ho imparata
bene memoria belle speranze per i
giovani ce ne sono tanti qua c'è il
principio di equità intergenerazionale
scritto lì dobbiamo garantirvi un
pianeta in condizioni non peggiori di
quello che l'abbiamo
fatto noi sono parole ma sono parole
importanti per cui potrete appellarvi se
non lo rispetteremo impegni di tutte le
nazioni presi dal basso con un nuovo
metodo di ndc tutti hanno detto che cosa
potevano fare in base alla loro
situazione
naturalmente diversa per i grandi
inquinatori o per i paesi in via di
sviluppo
tutti si sono impegnati ma come ben
sappiamo se aspettiamo i governi sarà
troppo poco e tardi obiettivo ambizioso
impegni ampiamente insufficienti
dovranno essere resi più ambiziosi
altrimenti andremo verso un
riscaldamento di circa 3,7 gradi
coop 21 chiede anche un impegno a
livello sub nazionale le città le
regioni anche le imprese anche i singoli
cittadini la comunità locali ma tutti a
questo punto mi chiedono cosa posso fare
io il solito decalogo eccetera eccetera
è finito ve lo dico subito il tempo di
chiudere rubinetto mentre ti dà evidenti
è importante sì stupido spiegare acqua
così ma le azioni devono essere molto
più forti e ambiziose anche nel singolo
vivere quotidiano
e vero eliminare gli sprechi ma gli
sprechi sono la punta dell'iceberg è
quello che ha fondato il titanic non è
stata la punta ma la parte sommersa
dell'iceberg
ecco quindi il mio nuovo decalogo usa
fonti energetiche rinnovabili va in
bicicletta preferisci la bicicletta o se
usi l'auto usa appunto l'auto elettrica
o ibrida ma ricaricata fonti energetiche
rinnovabili
chiedi che la tua città diventi smart e
resiliente fi pressione sui tuoi
rappresentanti politici o impegnati tu
stesso migliore all'isolamento della tua
casa parlane con gli amici con i
familiari con i colleghi con gli
insegnanti a scuola parla né di fronte
una bella tavola imbandita facendo
rifiuti zero portiamo i piatti da noi
con un cibo buono locale biologico e
anche resilienza perché anche il cibo
una grossa parte d'importanza nel
combattere i cambiamenti climatici
tutela le foreste i suoi abitanti lo
farò andando studiare la biodiversità il
prossimo mese in costa rica metteremo
una bella webcam così vi saluta vadalà
riduciamo 0 i rifiuti
smettiamo di fare rifiuti decarbonizzato
la nostra società non significa togliere
di mezzo il carbone ma dire ciao
possibili fossili abbandonare questo
modello basato su petrolio carbone e
anche gas
a questo punto dovrai avviarmi verso le
fine a c'è prima internet e galline che
cosa pensate per un futuro sostenibile
per i giovani un nuovo stile di vita non
solo alla tecnologia ma anche i modelli
adottare uno stile di vita internet e
galline significa cercare di unire le
conoscenze del passato le saggezze del
passato stili di vita sobri con le
tecnologie e le belle cose che abbiamo
oggi siamo proprio alla fine
qui volevo raccontarvi la barzelletta
dei due pianeti
ci sono due pianeti che vagano nello
spazio uno mai messo tutto malandato un
bel grosso e rigoglioso pieno di
vegetazione quello mai messo dice a
quello malandato ma che hai
taci vela una infestazione di homo
sapiens mi stanno del suo restando fanno
buchi dappertutto
ho perso la calotta artica non so più
come fare e tu ti vedo bene in forma
guarda stai tranquillo l'ho avuto
anch'io ma una cosa che passa per finire
siamo di fronte a un bivio difficile non
ho finito la strada più facile non è
detto che sui a quella migliore non
chiedere la strada a chi la sa già
ma andiamo con quelli come noi che la
stanno cercando grazie